[Musique]
la course au soleil pour bien son nom
c'est sous un temps magnifique les
coureurs se sont élancés dimanche et
lundi des yvelines à saint cyr l'école
et où un vil sur mansion depuis douze
ans le département accueille de
paris-nice lundi 8 mars c'était la
journée internationale des droits des
femmes
à cette occasion la commune de ben et la
préfecture des yvelines ont signé une
convention pour lutter contre les
violences sexistes et sexuelles
les services municipaux seront mobilisés
auprès des associations et des services
de l'état
une semaine marquée par l'accélération
de la vaccination dans le département
après un week end où 1700 personnes ont
été vaccinées au vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
la vie reprend un peu son cours dans les
ehpad la précarité étudiante au coeur
des préoccupations dans le département
de nombreuses initiatives commencent à
se développer
l'association élan coeur organisé une
distribution de colis alimentaires à est
en cours de son côté le conseil
départemental prévoit 1,2 million
d'euros pour venir en aide aux étudiants
gérard ramond s'est éteint à l'âge de 86
ans ce sculpteur est à l'origine de
nombreuses oeuvres présentes à maurepas
il avait aussi travaillé de pair avec
l'urbaniste et jacques riboud lors de la
construction de la ville nouvelle
[Musique]